[Music]
you came here
as desperate people
you came here to heal
my perfect strangers is a story about
nine individuals who are dealing with
their own personal traumas they go to a
wellness spa run by a woman played by
nicole kidman
it's based on the novel by liam moriarty
who wrote big little eyes
it's written by david e kelly so it's
pretty exciting
the people who come here
they come for the suffering
i don't want to suffer
you're already suffering
[Music]
it's such an unexpected story nine
people that do not know each other show
up for all different reasons
and they find themselves forced together
in
very unusual circumstances
[Music]
in ten days you will not be the person
that you are now
i am gonna fix you
these nine perfect strangers find out
that they've been chosen to be a part of
this spa experience
as the show unfolds they will find out
that they've been placed together for a
reason
this is particularly volatile group
let's start the protocol
[Music]
through a very unusual and alternative
form of therapy
marcia takes us on a very unusual
journey and we question a lot about
ourselves and each other
about how the place is run and about
what she's making us do
i'm not sure what i'm doing here
i've been feeling unlike myself
have you all gone mad
it's quite a journey and it's funny and
it's crazy and wonderful
and in the most unconventional ways
everybody ends up at a very different
place from where they start
and you just don't know what's coming
next
you want to get well
you want to heal
surrender yourself to me
[Music]
you